[Music]
the official over time
the voice cast of our
war-torn past ask us to
learn how our history and we
have the video we exercised from this
place of ashes bringing it back to the life
that is ours  work keep him here we
are gorongosa national park
rangers located in mozambique
our home that departs from each of us
everything we did to protect him
we are young we are old
we are mother
we are fathers and daughters we
all work 5  together to keep the
park safe
but this is not a primitive religion the
untouched thousands of people live
around the park where life on both
sides chosen as inspectors
we fight for coexistence everyday
still some people enter the
park illegally to hunt  the animals
i know because i was one of them
is the one that hunted antelopes and i knew the bush
like the back of my hand i was the fifth
existing patient i
walked many kilometers alone  about setting
a trap
usually i couldn't catch anything until
i got caught in mozambique court
when name 39 days in prison
i live is a community around
park with my
family life here is not
easy most people  there are no
conditions here but now we produce more
new ones and more flames because of
the priest's help promoting in this way the
increase for everyone there is no longer the
pressure to practice hunting as a way
to survive it
took a while for me to realize
if there was no  park everything that
makes our home beautiful and unique that
will be gone
if we can keep the park we can
work and live and prosper
when i look at who i was in the past
who i am today i am hard to believe
how far i have come i stay  satisfied
when I learned that the park that had
forgiven that I made a past and who
allowed them to make him employed
am good at my job because I know
how hunters think of me p  I was
always one step closer to them
I was lucky but there are different ways for
other beneficiaries and that's why
working hard to protect this place
I know I will never remarry and
I hope others realize that they
deserve a second chance
like here I had as  to blame
I call the ministry it won't be generated
I feel proud to be a
gorongosa national park ranger
[Music]